it's the tenth season of The Walking
Dead which is hard to believe bananas
right it's nuts and they have they have
I've been interviewing everybody on that
cast since the beginning of the show
people have been coming and then they
come here and I interviewed them and
then when they're when they're killed
off they come here and everyone's been
killed off left and right and you
survived I don't know how you survived
you have threaded this amazing needle
you've watched cast mates left and right
get taken out how would you feel or how
are you gonna feel if and when they come
to you and say guess what it's a secret
but tomorrow's your last episode we're
killing you off I'll burn down that
building you're there because they're
really scared of you yeah every day with
a lighter okay great well we have a clip
here from The Walking Dead and I don't
know how you guys do it but they managed
to keep you think you can't raise the
stakes anymore and you guys just it just
keeps the team behind this show all of
you you just keep doing it and doing it
and doing it yeah this season's great
yeah it's really really good all right
here's the scene I think where you are
you're trying to ride through and you
you someone's clearly blocking your path
I'm doing it in kind of an ingenious way
let's take a look at this clip from The
Walking Dead cool
[Music]
[Music]
Felix paddy was gonna be like this now
we're getting through
it's negan steak The Walking Dead airs
Sundays at 9:00 on AMC and check it out
ride with Norman Reedus
airs Sundays at midnight on AMC and it's
really cool Norman Reedus
good man
[Applause]